[MUSIC PLAYING]
CASSIE: Hello and welcome.
We're here at the security
zone at Next with Christiaan,
an expert in phishing
attacks at Google Cloud.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Hi
Cassie, happy to be here.
CASSIE: So phishing attacks
are a difficult problem
for security teams to solve.
And one of the most common ways
that phishing attackers get
access to sensitive data is
by stealing passwords, right?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Yeah.
Phishing attacks are getting
more sophisticated every day.
And attackers are
finding new ways
to trick employees into
accidentally handing over
their login information.
CASSIE: So if I'm
a security admin
and I'm trying to
protect employees
from having their passwords
stolen, where do I even start?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Let's walk
through an example here.
A phishing attacker starts
by setting up a fake website.
And that website
will look exactly
like the real login
page or the service
that you're trying to log into.
So the attacker would
then send a link
to this phishing
page to the employee.
And that employee then
types their username
and their password into
that phishing website.
CASSIE: So the employee has
just typed their username
and password into a
completely fake phishing site?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Exactly.
And-- but then happens
is the attacker
opens up the real
website and they then
replay this username
and password
into that legitimate website.
What's, furthermore, is the
legitimate websites then
will send a real two factor
authentication prompt or a code
to the user's device.
The user, unknowingly,
accepts the prompt or types
their OTP, one time password,
code into the attacker's site
and, now, the
attacker, not only have
your username and your
password, they even
have your 2FA code that
will give them access
to all of your systems.
With single sign on
being so widespread,
once the attacker has
access to one system,
it makes it really trivial
for them to gain access
to all other systems
with any sensitive data
that the employee
then has access to.
CASSIE: So the employee thinks
that they just securely logged
into a legitimate site
where, in actual fact,
their account just
got compromised?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Exactly.
Phishing attacks like
these are getting
much more sophisticated
at tricking users
into giving up their
sensitive login information.
This is really a huge
problem for companies today.
A recent data breach
report by Verizon
estimated that 81% of
account compromises
last year were due
to vulnerabilities
associated with passwords.
CASSIE: Wow.
That's a lot.
So how can companies
protect employees
from falling for these
sophisticated stolen
password and 2FA attacks?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND:
So companies can
protect employees against
these types of attacks
by providing all employees
with FIDO security keys
that connect to their devices.
Google just launched its
own FIDO certified key
called the Titan Security Key.
It provides a phishing-resistant
second factor of authentication
that prevents attackers from
gaining access to systems,
even if the attacker has
stolen the employee's password.
CASSIE: So how do these
security keys work?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND:
Well, let's take a look
at our employee again.
So this time, with the
Titan Security Key,
when they open up
a login page, they
will be prompted to
touch the security
key connected to their device.
When they touch
the key, not only
is an encrypted code sent
to Google servers, which
validate that the user has
access to their Titan Security
Key, but it also
ensures that the user
is on a legitimate
Google login page.
Really neat.
CASSIE: So even if the attacker
steals the employee's password
and then tries to
relay their login,
they still can't get
access because they
have no way of
physically authenticating
without the employee's
security key.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Exactly.
Now, let's try security keys
out to show you how they work.
So on the first
laptop, let's look
at a user trying to sign in.
So this user is clearly
on some phishing website
and let's see how the
security key is going
to protect this user,
even though they're
in the midst of falling
for a phishing attack.
So can I have that
security key for a moment?
Thank you so much.
So this user will go ahead
insert their security key,
try to enter their password
into this phishing website,
and, at this point, when
she's trying to log in,
the security key is
going to stop her
from signing in because clearly
she's on a phishing website.
And even though she
didn't realize it,
the security key did and
stopped her from signing in.
CASSIE: OK.
So this is actually going
to work on the real site
or is it just going
to block both of them?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: So
let's take a quick look.
So on this laptop, Cheryl is on
the right Google sign in page,
right?
If we investigate that URL up
top, everything looks good.
So I'm going to go ahead, I'm--
CASSIE: You're
going to need this.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Oh,
thank you so much.
So, I'm going to
go ahead and I'm
going to enter
Cheryl's password here,
but before I do, of
course, I, first,
need to enter the security key.
I'm going to go ahead,
I'm going to click,
and, now, you'll see how
simple this really is.
All she has to do is touch
the button on the security key
and she will be magically
signed in with the security
key protecting her against
potential phishing.
CASSIE: Fantastic.
I love how simple that is.
And it's a whole new
level of protection
against phishing attacks.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND:
Exactly, right?
So, Titan Security Keys work
hand-in-hand with Google
and the Chrome browser
to provide employees
with end-to-end
phishing protection.
In addition, Titan
Security Keys include
firmware, developed by Google,
to verify the key's integrity.
They're built on
open FIDO standards
and that allows
these keys to be used
with lots of other services,
including Salesforce, Facebook,
and more.
CASSIE: So how can someone get
started with security keys?
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: So
Titan Security Keys
will soon be available for
sale on the Google Store.
And if you're a
Google Cloud customer,
you can also get
these immediately
through your account executive.
You can also use any
compatible FIDO security key
from any other vendor
with Google products.
And once you have your keys, you
just need to G.co/SecurityKey
for further instructions.
CASSIE: Well, Christiaan,
thanks so much for walking us
through how the stolen
password attacks work
and how we can protect
against them with Google
Cloud and Titan Security Keys.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: My pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]